there you go
it's that word duty like is it your duty
to have sex with me as a as a wife or as
a partner yeah i think so if i married a
dude yeah i would like that but i don't
know if it would be like a duty like oh
if you don't do that i i don't know like
it's just the word you wouldn't you
wouldn't expect it okay you wouldn't
want your wife to have sex with you
whenever you wanted
yeah
but if look if she told me like look i'm
not feeling
100 today i would not be like no have
sex i mean yeah you can have an off day
at your job but your job is still
like
you can have a day where you you're off
and you feel sick your boss might say
okay it's fine but it's still your job
exactly look if you kept doing it be
like okay what's what's going on here
yeah are you not attracted to all the
questions you're not attracted to me are
you doing what what's the reason why
yeah but if she obviously
did it like for
a few days a week maybe
i don't see it as a duty
okay i don't know i feel like um like
our generation has like a negative
like connotation to the word duty so
sometimes when we hear duty we just kind
of hear it as like a burden or or you
like i don't actually want to do it
willingly but i feel like when i if you
reframe it sometimes duties like it's an
honor it's actually like okay like it's
your duty maybe like to serve your
country or to do something that you're
proud of and so that's kind of in that
context of a relationship i would frame
it that way but i would still disagree
with the point of whether a man is
intact
what was your point about from the man's
perspective sorry um the question i
asked was why is it okay for women to
feel entitled to be protected and
provided for but it's wrong for a man to
feel entitled to sex and intimacy
because well i mean maybe this room
mostly agrees but like in general when i
ask women this question typically it's
well what if the extreme scenario the
worst thing's ever happened to me ever
they go straight into
that their body is being objectified
yeah they only are wanted because of
their body when it's innate and men to
want that from a female but going back
to the question before if
a woman is is her duty to
please a man sexually when does that
duty start since we're saying that man
has a duty to protect his girlfriend
from jump does a woman have the duty to
give her man the sexual pleasures from
jump since
that is
um i'm sorry but for me the way i see it
is right if you want me to be monogamous
with you you can't then just be like
okay i'll do this when i want you know
i'll only have sex with you and i want
because then you can't complain when if
the person cheats you can't
if you decide to not make it a duty you
can't complain when he cheats also like
imagine like
say you go out and she starts to fight
someone starts to fight with her you're
like well this time i don't exactly
exactly
why do you think male sexuality is so
stigma stigmatized why must men put up
with female hormones being emotional and
crazy but women can't put up with male
hormones being horny
corny
i think people just it's it's what's
expected now you know as a man you're
meant to you're expected to be stoic or
to not
show or to just be in control of what
you're doing and so if you fall short in
any sense it's somewhat seen
in a bad way um by society whereas we're
women
sorry with women um people kind of
make allowances um even if it's they're
having a bad day or because of their
period or whatever you know we always
have an excuse for it and so it's okay
so i think that's what it is
i also think uh
um
[Music]
a misconception is like
i think
it's often
viewed that men are always in the mood
or most of the time we're in the mood
you know which
isn't the case like sometimes we've just
had a long day
you know we're not trying to like end
in a case where you know
you know your woman is like
laid the roses out and all of that stuff
and
you might not be
in a mood that she's and so you kind of
have to
but it's always perceived that there's
something wrong in the relationship
which just isn't the case because when
when it's the opposite you know when the
lady's like not in the mood you know
we're supposed to be understanding
um
but if you guys say no then the girls
then the girls say what's wrong what's
the problem you're cheating
fast
i i think men and women display
mental illness differently
i think especially when it comes to
hormones
and sometimes we ascribe hormonal
behavior as mental illness you know
we'll we'll see a woman that's going
through hormonal changes and we'll call
it crazy
we'll see a man that's going through
hormonal changes and we'll call it a
midlife crisis
but that's just basically the change
that happens in their hormones they're
at a different stage in their life
and things are changing that they can't
control
and it
comes out it's in the craziness you more
hyperbole than anything it's more just
you exaggerating and just saying you
know you're just acting wild it's not
necessarily saying they have mental
illness
i i think
yeah maybe sometimes i mean i know in my
own experience i i i see your point that
sometimes maybe we can use words in the
extreme and maybe we're just
you know like halfway about it you're
crazy
not saying that she's gonna pull out a
knife and yeah do something
although i have known some that might
um but
but i guess my point is is you know
it's very uh in our society we we tend
to focus on
the struggles that women go through with
hormones and menopause and all that
but when
viewing that men from that same lens
and the changes they go through
and
how our hormones affect our decision
making
i think often it's just labeled as toxic
a man who's
corny
might um act a certain way so he's just
a dirty old man
when
that's probably how he's been acting for
the previous 30 40 years and how he's
probably gonna act for the next 20 years
that's just him being a man with
testosterone
in my opinion can i also it's kind of
like you said before as a man you're
supposed to
control your emotions and your feelings
and all that and your hormones and all
that
so it's not about them being horny it's
about them feeling you know what i mean
could i ask a question is that
okay like because obviously there's
mostly men here
how would you guys feel if like society
didn't sort of
curtail
a man's sexuality so if like we just
lived in a world where
every man's sexual desires was displayed
to the fullest would that be a healthy
would that be beneficial for society
i think it depends what you mean because
i don't think a lot of things would
there wouldn't be many successful men if
everyone was given into all of their um
you know desires sexual desires and you
know a lot of men would be in very
not very good situations if you know
they were just doing whatever they
wanted i think sexual discipline is a
good thing in a sense question for the
man have you ever tried nofap
eight years she's laughing
eight years what is voluntary selling no
verb seem
retention it was very difficult
and it produced a lot of problems and i
made a lot of bad decisions